oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
topaziola welcome back to another
episode of the dope as usual podcast we
are here to talk about life drugs
accomplishments problems and everything
in between today we have a very special
guest you guys may recognize him from
[ __ ] skating around everywhere this
is boo johnson pro skater what's up dude
with the beer and the mushrooms ingested
already yeah man we're on the groovy one
tonight yeah i was over there he's like
i took some mushrooms on the driveway
like [ __ ]
you well prepared yo you like mushrooms
bro i got this t-shirt i just came out
with like well actually i love that
mushrooms five minutes yeah i mean my
boy bro [ __ ] yeah dude so what'd you do
today
that's what i want to know because you
look like you are chilling i'm chilling
but i'm tired bro i worked hard today so
top of the morning got up
worked out then i had to go to physical
therapy in costa mesa to see dr g
my knee is a little like [ __ ] up i had
surgery about oh [ __ ] in the beginning
of the year in january i had meniscus
surgery
skating you know
maybe thrashing out there it happens you
know it's part of the job
but anyways um you know i just gotta
maintain it it's you know i treat my
body body like a car you know your car
needs maintenance when you're whipping
it around you're being a little reckless
that's how i look at the body so i had
to jump in there get a little
maintenance a little rubbage on the knee
then i jammed home
what else did i do
that's how i feel every day wait what
the [ __ ] i know i was like
i know i had some [ __ ]
i jammed home
uh went to the shop for a minute
now i went back to my house walked my
dogs
then i went to the shop linked up with
the boys what shop my skate shop
pharmacy board shop i own a um skate
shop in downtown long beach really
survive that's yours yeah that's my shot
it's called pharmacy yep we've been
there since 2014. so oh no no 2016. take
that back this is a long time yeah bro
it's i've actually just moved locations
into a bigger better spot literally
one store over so we're still on the
same block nothing changed just new
location i did not know you own a skate
shop yeah bro [ __ ] cool man you might
learn a thing of that
yeah that's sick
what is this right here
oh jhf just have fun that's also my
company that i started
clothing brand clothing brand and
more just a lifestyle it's a motto that
i live by you feel me that i want to
push out to the world and let the people
know you know it's all about just having
fun no matter what you do in life but
we'll get to get back on that topic so i
met the boys at pharmacy jumped in the
truck and we went to
um some skate park in like garden grove
it was actually oh no garden [ __ ] like
we're getting it in for like two three
hours sweating my ass off and knowing i
already worked out this morning you feel
me i got it in
when skated
i probably look a little dark right now
because i was in the not all bad day
with no shirt on
and yeah went back home and just kicked
it got some food and
you know now i'm here so that was work
though right that's great yeah even
though i'm out there just having fun
that's like me clocking in for the day
and it takes a whole toll on my body so
when we talked to we had jeron on pro
skater but
he's not really on the he's like
he's not out there every day anymore
he's got you know his kids he's got his
other brand going on but you're out here
every single day
what what is how do i know a lot of
people pro skater be sick what do you
guys do all day you smoke [ __ ] weed
all day no yeah you do more what do you
what what is your job like you go to
shows you go to competitions do you just
sponsorships photo shoots what is it
it's a lot bro it's like
that's why being a professional
skateboarder is like it's not only about
being good on the skateboard it's not
only about skateboarding you got to be a
all-around well-rounded
professional you know in every lane and
that goes from waking up early
being on time to meetings you feel me
responding to emails that you don't want
to look at you are your brand you are
your brand at the end of the day you're
an independent contractor and you got to
like put your place together you don't
have a coach like a normal like sport
you feel me telling you
what to do what place to run you got to
like actually make these plays happen
for yourself even though you might be
sponsored and they're giving you like a
platform to like create yourself but
a lot of people like rely on these
companies to build on them then they get
slept on and so on so
just being an all-rounded person who's
on top of their [ __ ]
they're out there
waking up you don't have to work out but
if you're trying to sleep bro you're an
athlete we're athletes so i'm waking up
early like any athlete will i'm in the
gym
working out strengthening my knees my
arms
and just for that everyday endurance you
feel me i'm riding my bicycle i'm
running i'm doing anything i can to
enhance my my capability of yeah
um walking good and skating good
honestly because that's you know if i'm
carrying myself well
that's me being professional yeah like
i've said before i i don't want to give
some athlete like 300 million dollar
contract fool's overweight
[ __ ] man you know what i said we were
talking about this in a couple episodes
ago
i wouldn't trust it's like yo his
discipline is obviously not there yeah
even though he's good
it's just not it doesn't show yeah it's
almost like police officers i always
feel like crazy lazy
now you're just cheating yourself right
you don't look like the same [ __ ] you
know so you know i got you know yeah i
try be the best me
yeah socially and
just carrying myself right and trying
like create plays and going outside of
skateboarding you know to
to let
my skate companies
see me on like a higher level like oh
he's out there doing other plays you
know maybe he could
he he's on his other creative [ __ ] maybe
he could you know i i'm more of an asset
than like
yeah i'm not just taking from the
company i'm trying to put on on my side
for the company you know because if i'm
winning in this lane in that lane
dgk stray pharmacy jhf they're they're
also winning you know
so
yeah man just being professional yeah
being unprofessional that's really what
it is you know because i i mean
it takes one person to [ __ ] off emails
and go well this guy's not i'm out oh
yeah he took too long [ __ ] over he if
he really cared he'd be back yeah he
would hit me back already timing's
everything like i learned that
excuse me at an early age bro like
alright i'm i'm that dude who's gonna be
at the meeting
10 15 even maybe 30 minutes early you
feel me i'm not yeah i can't stand being
late you know
i came a little late today but i texted
you guys i'm gonna be that it was early
i pulled it up at what time like 8 15.
i'll say you were the first person
that's ever been [ __ ] i was here i
ate i just drove around the block i went
and got me a little motel
but i'm gonna make sure i'm here on time
because that's what professional does no
matter how big or little the person is
of course see that's what you'll never
lose man yeah you will never lose that
way good business goes a long way yeah
it does man it can't be burning bridges
out here [ __ ] be blowing
opportunities without even like
realizing
what that opportunity could have brought
them in the long run you know
because i think a lot of people don't
like
i know i'm not saying it's all luck i'm
saying we're lucky to be able to you
wake up and do exactly what the [ __ ] you
love to do oh yeah yeah not a lot of
people get that when they do and
squander it they don't remember like yo
remember when you worked at mcdonald's
that [ __ ] was boring as [ __ ] look at you
now yeah and then you're squandering
[ __ ] yeah right now that's it people
always say that too like man i wish i
could live your life this and that but
i'll let someone step in my shoes for a
couple days you feel me it looks
beautiful
it's like a lot of work it's a lot of
work bro it's maintaining it's
sacrificing is sometimes being a
[ __ ] but just being real you know
it's like it takes a lot bro like
everyone thinks about a lot of [ __ ] and
it's like all right man just
think you gotta look you gotta just
understand other people and no
everyone goes through [ __ ] bro no matter
what for sure
and um
it doesn't matter rich or poor bro
that's a beautiful struggle and we all
struggle like and it's
you gotta hustle through it you know
it's just knowledgeable maybe if i'm not
working hard in a certain lane as like
they're like hands-on
trust me i'm i'm working hard in a
certain lane that i know that's growth
for me
yeah yeah like i uh delegate delegate
man not everybody can it can do
accounting not everybody's an accountant
and not everybody can do [ __ ] stairs
and kick flips and [ __ ] right not
everybody that's okay yeah and that's
fine you just gotta grow your team
around you like we talk about it all the
time growing a team around you but when
you're by yourself you're doing your own
thing
you are your own team all the time your
your assistant you know i mean you're
your own personal trainer your own
motivator all that [ __ ]
especially for you especially for an
athlete someone that has to
[Music]
has to be disciplined if not you don't
[ __ ] succeed anymore
straight up bro
even if you get comfortable you start
chilling you think everything's good bro
bro how long you been skating
professionally professional i turned pro
in 2014 bro oh it's recent bro she
thought yeah well like seven years you
know but
when i say recents like you know i was
like [ __ ] fourteen you know i mean
oh yeah yeah nah that wasn't i'm not
holding houston i'm 28. 28. okay okay so
for
like right before like 22 and i've been
skating since i was like 13 you know so
it's been a build bro it's been such a
grind and like was that all you were
going for as a kid
well i mean once you packed it up hey
once i picked it up and i got sponsored
i was like oh this is it you feel me
like
i ain't gotta listen to no one bro like
i could just be a [ __ ] rebel and like
run the streets and do whatever the [ __ ]
i want and like be cool with like all my
homies and like
have this image of just being like you
know raw straight up in the streets and
still have like
still have like a you feel me when
people see you they're like damn what
the [ __ ] are
yeah exactly you know like being a
skater was just very
very diverse and like a lot of [ __ ] you
know now it is that's like almost being
a rock star 100 everybody wants to be a
skater you know like everybody wants to
be that guy [ __ ] going and
clearing gaps
since i was a kid my mom used to my mom
used to get thrasher every week uh was
it yeah
yeah so she had it from the 90s so when
i was starting to skate skating she gave
me like three to four stacks like that
the [ __ ] up
yeah she had them all so i'd go through
them and i thought like oh these guys
are this is their [ __ ] job and then
when the fools had the full spreads that
would go out further
oh [ __ ] i should cut them out put them
on my wall that [ __ ] was tight man my
mom that's what i mean cool about that's
what's so cool about skateboarding is
like everyone relates to it
somehow it's like if their cousin did it
if their mom got the magazines if their
grandparents got a magazine from
albertsons or
whatever the case is bro like
somehow people always are relevant with
skateboarding you bring it up someone's
got something to say yeah yeah yeah
that's sick man that's a cool sport bro
i'm super blessed to be in that
community
so were you born or raised i was born in
lancaster california
i grew up in tehachapi california that's
so it's like here's palmdale lancaster
you go back in the hills 30 minutes and
that's tax free then you go like another
30 minutes that's bakersfield you feel
me that's what i said okay
so it's like in that zone it's a little
valley town i know where you're at it's
super fire like it was a chill town
growing up
in the cups though yeah it's in the cuts
so you grew up
just drugs or have kids
was that the content that's exactly what
it is yeah same with me that's exactly
what it is like all my all my home girls
that i grew up with like in elementary
and [ __ ] most of them are married got
kids you feel me very
a lot i've had homies passed away from
doing drugs out there just on some
[ __ ] you know especially out toward
me that's that's all bad
it's a little trap you know but my mom
was cool as [ __ ] you know she raised me
well she taught me you know she wanted
me to have the childhood she had you
know just
being on [ __ ] being do whatever we
want and just have fun and that's what
she supported i played all sports soccer
football oh yeah you know like
have the opportunity to do whatever i
want then like skating came along and
she started taking us out out to la for
contests and [ __ ] you know that's when i
was able to see the world i was like
whoa like hold on like i've seen this in
skate
mags and [ __ ] but i didn't know it was
like right here you know yeah like
homies that skate contests are showing
me like their zone and all the spots
they live at or all the spots that are
around them i'm like
start coming out here staying on my
homies couches and like really living
that skate life next was that
um
like 15 like 14 like 14 15 i was like
you feel me tap in with my homies out
here coming out here on the weekends
taking the train from lancaster my mom
would drive me a lancaster i'll jump on
the train from lancaster to the la union
station
my homies would pick me up or the homie
deville
would pick me up
and just
sleep on homies couches for the week
weekend you know i had forty dollars in
my pocket and just made it work good
[ __ ] when i was 17
i
dipped out to the valley i was in um
where was i in the valley
i was in the valley for like
six months one month
well i moved from my mom's house yeah at
17 2017. she let me go bro i was on like
i was still in high school too and i was
supposed to be doing my work
didn't do it
you feel me but she thought i was doing
it moved to the valley for a little bit
i dipped out to long beach
like six months later after the valley
and been out there ever since bro you
left at 17 to come skate yeah right damn
you've been on your own for over a
decade yeah man that's my mom she'll
tell you too she's like this boy
i literally have not lived at my house
since i was 17. it's crazy i literally
been too i didn't pay i was living with
someone
so i was like 18. you feel me like i
lived in the valley lived with the homie
six months moved out to about to long
beach with homie cole matthews the team
manager of element at the time nice word
company i was driving for it so you were
deep
i was deep yeah you were d that's what
you wanted to do right there
see every time i've talked to somebody
that does skate that's always like well
that's everything that's my whole life's
all i do it's all i think about it's all
you strive what's any sport you gotta be
passionate about what whatever you do
you feel me i look at it as a sport too
this is real [ __ ] it's in the olympics
now yeah actually that was so [ __ ]
cool to see bro it's not it's getting so
crazy you know it's it's it's definitely
a sport
yeah so what i'm saying like the
dedication you moved out yeah that's the
same thing this full this will play
college basketball that's all he [ __ ]
did he moved to go to school same exact
channel
so when i see it it i just sold [ __ ]
weed but i moved on my own to go so we
do all that [ __ ] but the determination
is there every time i've talked to
somebody as an athlete it's the same
like almost the same steps like no i did
it on my own every [ __ ] day that's
what i did sleep on a couch if i have to
yeah
it's just natural you know it's in our
blood to do [ __ ]
extreme [ __ ] and like keep it going
that's [ __ ] hard if you love it if
you got passion yeah now i used to skate
i started when i was like four to about
14 15 and then i just started selling
weed yeah um
i'm that kid i'm a [ __ ] fat kid so
i'm over here like seeing all my six
foot three white kids
hit stairs and [ __ ] the loading docks
at raley's i'm like don't break my damn
leg trying to jump on the floating dock
but i could always hit those parking
curbs real quick board slide real quick
thought i was as [ __ ]
i thought i was tired you're having fun
bro i always have to get in that rush
like i always say
a lot of times there's excuse for me
like we're going to skateboard and we
just go smoke weed at the park yeah a
lot of the times yeah but i love to do
but
yeah i just started hitting my head
trying to hit my tailbone bro
the tailbone
what about your shins the [ __ ] i don't
care about as much
it's my tailbone cause i'm held a hell
of it hella heavy
all my weight ah
like you ever get that purple bruise
right above your [ __ ] ass
and it's like a deep black spine
black and purple bro what's the worst
energy you've ever wiped out like that
in front of though i know
yes bro i was skating around all the
time like oh and jerome goes oh you know
how to write a board
that touched my heart [ __ ] that
was great bam [ __ ] no bro like this
smacked my [ __ ] as [ __ ]
but uh yeah i was just tired of hurting
myself but i gave that up
um
sorry dude i got sidetracked right now
yes i did eat [ __ ]
that was legendary though i'm surprised
that shouldn't make sportscenter i
[ __ ] myself up but i'm okay it [ __ ]
did hurt
[Music]
oh
um so i want to talk about it you
got sponsored at 21. essentially um got
sponsored at 14. then went pro oh went
pro okay so at 14. so at 13 you really
pick it up your mom's supporting you and
you get sponsored by who at 14. pharmacy
board shop the so the one that you own
yeah the one i own they now they
franchise me my own shopping long get
the [ __ ] out of here
and there they go i got sponsored by
them in palmdale you feel me because
palm down lancaster they're the closest
like shop next to me so how do they know
about you just kept going in there
you're that kid i was just going there
buying boards and the crazy thing is the
filmer terry larue
that i filmed he was the filmer for them
had the [ __ ] vx and everything bro
he lived and grew up into hatchery so he
seemed like me and my little brother
skating up at the park
and he'll come up
to
the local park with like keel and dad
andrew sausage all these brain freezers
out there that skate it for pharmacy you
feel me and they're on the come up i'm
like whoa what the [ __ ] you know and
they'll see us and i realized who they
were and that's made me even go pharmacy
more you know like damn dude like now
you're sick they're out here [ __ ] now
you have examples stickers i got an
example of like what it takes
started talking to terry he is a homie
and yeah next you know dude [ __ ] mom
i started skating with terry
he went to take me out to like palmdale
and vegas without my mom you know you
know skate missions you got to jump in
the van and go film
terry had to talk to my mom and because
she's like wait who's this [ __ ]
strong man grown ass
man taking my son
out of the county 13 14 years you know
this nigga's like yo your son bro you
got your chance your son got potential
miss johnson like and i remember one
late night like we went out skating and
she you know she's all right
next thing you know like you know a
couple months went by we stacked some
clips got video tape put together since
it's pharmacy
and boom been on ever since bro they're
like this like they're literally family
and
i i've been in long beach for so long
they're like yo
i think we need a shop out here bro you
you want that i'm like wait when did
that happen
2016. oh that's right 16. so
backtrack a little bit you get sponsored
by them at 14 yep and you skate for them
for
i mean forever yeah forever ever since
so what is that like for you as a little
kid what because i ask every single
person that sits right here ask him what
was that moment when you when you're
like by yourself you went to your room
went
yo what the [ __ ] am i doing here like oh
[ __ ] that happens to me all the time see
that's a good feeling though it's like
good job [ __ ] because that's
what it is being a professional too it's
like
everyone says like damn man like you
made it this and that like
i personally don't feel like i'll ever
make it as a human bro i personally
don't think i it's never a finish line
bro like i thought the first time i i
was i made 50 000 i was like oh
the more money the more like you realize
like
i don't have any money from the first
hundred thousand dollars i made i'm like
oh [ __ ] like
i i need to [ __ ] get up here to even
get a [ __ ] house that i
i'm looking at you know but all the baby
steps of getting to that twenty thousand
ten thousand bro it's like it's
gratitude but
i know i gotta work there's no sleeping
like we were talking about earlier bro
the grind we're very like everything you
said i think every day you know we're so
busy but it's like
if i want to be comfortable when i'm 80
i got to [ __ ] work bro
you know like
60 we're still working bro for sure my
grandma's 88 so it works so it
works really nice i see old dudes
[ __ ] running past me when i'm out
working i'm like
and i'm i'll be complaining on my 30th
crunch
[ __ ] that bro like i'mma still have to
do this while i'm 50 years old like no
matter what like we're all going to be
doing this still so you might as well
hustle even harder right now you know
that's exactly what i was saying is it
worked man people always try to say like
oh like
you know okay i get some money this and
that like it's like bro i'm where i'm
working i give you 5 000 that's taken
away from my pocket bro like i'm trying
to get to a point where you don't have
to ask me and you already see i got it
bro but yeah you know i ain't got it
and that's it's all about the work ethic
bro yes it's non-stop you if you like
realize it i like that new drake song
[ __ ] i ever heard it a lot of people
know the price or what's that
the price you know the price of
everything for the value of nothing
everyone that's a good ass one that's a
good it's a good lyric man they don't
know that that's true as [ __ ] though i
mean it's like
you know how much it is but the value of
something you know yeah i come from the
bottom
you grew up with no money i grew up no
money yeah well i don't like here food
stamps yeah me like no money bro even my
family still now like we still live in
the same crib bro like grew up with a
big family bro we still doing our [ __ ]
though you feel me like you're not an
only child nah bro how many brothers
just you got six brothers oh my dad
my dad's side
we got a whole bunch of
stuff dad still having kids nah not
anymore bro like not anymore what's your
youngest sibling you got now youngest
sibling he just turned
on like on my mom's side you feel me
like my
that i really see every day he's
15 or 16. oh yeah i got lavelle he's the
oldest
he's just turned 30 i'm the second
oldest
28 my brother isaiah he just turned
25 on the 19th yesterday oh [ __ ]
two days ago two days ago
then alicia she's 21.
sophia thinks she's 18 and keelan
he's
said 15 15 16. yeah my little my little
littlest brother's eight my dad never
stopped okay cool he's a youngin dancer
he was born what two thousand
[ __ ]
thirteen damn bro
even even my little homie brother i'm
like hold on bro [ __ ] are born in like
any 2000 it's crazy to me in my brain it
is because because i'm i just turned 32
the other day okay so when i think i'm
like wait
2 000 what the [ __ ] was smoking weed
almost but that's every generation you
feel me it's just weird he's like damn
if you're born in 1993. damn they get
like
but it is just generations but
it's a nude yeah when you get older yeah
and you're getting like huh because you
know when you're like 15 oh damn that
[ __ ] is 25. you don't got a
house yet [ __ ]
because you think about that [ __ ] you
see on tv like oh you're supposed to
have a house you'd be married and have a
career and then you're 25 and going well
i just need to sack a wee that's all i'm
trying to do today i don't have a
[ __ ] business i don't understand it
[Music]
well like you said like um oh i made
money oh no that's not that's just my
taxes [ __ ]
i want to get a house oh [ __ ] you and in
l.a i'm looking at encino engine going
wow
an extra million dollars because it's in
this area [ __ ] you
and as a kid
man it's california but like you said if
you grew up with no money isn't it weird
that you're like wait i made money now
yeah oh i gotta [ __ ] work as hard as
that that's why i work non-stop dude
we're on that mindset you know like it's
very good bro like
you make sure i love it yeah it makes
you don't like i can't stop bro
i'm so glad to hear this i feel like
he's the first guest out of all the
guests we've had on the season to come
on and talk about like discipline like
an athlete
like nobody everything principles that
apply to success no matter what you're
getting after be it sports or whatever
yeah no that's how i look at it too like
no matter what lane you're into
get it you know get it while you can
exactly you could really
grow
from the concrete from anything any
business in the world the guy that makes
that can and the ink for that can and
then exactly
for my like brothers there's a guy right
there with a house behind every one of
these because he worked his ass off yeah
and you guys just like take that leap
and sometimes you get [ __ ] shut down
and you get stuck right there but you
gotta just [ __ ] stay sturdy and like
take that next sleep on the next
opportunity you know it's like it's all
about growth in this world it's like if
you if it's not it's like
like i got plants in my house bro i call
myself the mr green thumb bro cuz
regular plants regular plants bro
because if you if you could take care of
a plant
you're going to be well off gee like you
were on a schedule i can see it already
oh yeah you're up at the same time you
eat at the same time you do all that oh
yeah i made my schedule two weeks three
weeks ago now the best thing i ever did
in my life
and i'm like wait all right hey full eat
because i don't eat in the morning until
like four or five in the afternoon yeah
that's good or not but because i fast
too i don't i don't do anything
too yeah i don't do it that's a thing
it's never been on purpose
that's what i'm saying but i have the
schedule so i woke up and ate some fruit
this morning and i felt like [ __ ] i'm an
adult damn
growing up right now it feels great it
does dude he's like he's like you he
does the same [ __ ] we're on the same
you can't even tell people like oh you
you know i just did this today because
it's like
that's what i gotta do like
it's a program that i've been on and i'm
so strict on myself where it's just like
money if i wake up and i'm like
hey babe
gotta go you feel me come back in the
gym come back home shower
all right babe gotta go shaking his head
yep i didn't even have to look
disappointed and i already knew you're
doing this
it is so consistent it's like
i got so much love to give you feel me
when i type in my people i try to give
them
give everyone
all my attention even if you're [ __ ]
my homie grover on the [ __ ] street
you know i try to say what's up to
people be very [ __ ] open be real and
just be as genuine as as i can
to everyone because that's what it is
but at the same time i'm very strict
with my time and i got scheduled to be
you know no matter what it is you know
this is called being professional the
way you act and set policies for
yourself and that's the way you treat
yourself as a business you're the boss
and the worker this goes for everything
exactly
thank you like yeah boston they're
working because
any of my homies i'm gonna work if
you're doing i'm gonna work just as hard
as you you know if i'm
not thinking you know if i wasn't a
professional skateboarder we could call
my mom right now and mom if i was a pro
skater what would i be doing
i don't know something making money
doing something you know because that's
how i was i always i was mowing lawns
weed whacking selling candy out the
[ __ ]
trash can hella cans
like yeah crushing can't oh bro i did
that [ __ ] i did that when i lived i
moved to [ __ ]
long beach bro i was when i was still
skating getting little checks i was
still saving cans bro like crushing them
like fools have no idea you know yeah
that's like making that extra dollar you
feel me i'll always be like that i'll
always have like let's do any chore i
could at someone's house like yo
cool first first summer i bought my
first car i still took the bus to work
just to save on the parking
no because when you pulled up i go oh
that's not his car because you got the
matrix
because i just got my back the other
and when i was explaining the rapid goal
this guy i know he got this matrix rat
because i was talking about the day i
saw you
and uh i didn't get it but that's what i
referenced it was your card so when you
pulled up i was waiting for me oh it's
okay
yeah now i just dropped my car up my
bins off to my homie dude he does the
whole bust down with that satellite in
the
stores yes i just told you i want all
right
um what's this thing bro
bro that's awesome oh it looks amazing
but let me show you this photo of my car
right now
oh yeah starlight auto bro is the homie
so
oh [ __ ]
i just saw that clip of that one
we have right now is this yours yeah
the surprise but
here's the car
gotta love that rap dude
all right look what it looks like right
now though bro
that's my [ __ ] in the inside oh my god
that looks sad i was like whoa bro but
this whole car is gutted oh [ __ ]
yo it's so worth it it's like being the
kid and you had those little
glow-in-the-dark stars
except you're just smoking weed and
trapping you straight up
that's my favorite thing my truck's so
dark in the inside i was like damn i
might have to put when i was driving
here i was like man i might have to bust
the stars down in the air
yeah i brought out the truck so
um yeah even like i was saying like even
the truck bro i'm like
i can't drive it you know i gotta save
the miles on it you know i'm gonna
escape to skate park or something you
know but it's just weird [ __ ] like that
but that's how
you got you stay you stack your chips
that's how you you know i mean i'll
spend money on this and that but
i would suggest
i'm a stack i'm gonna make sure i'm
stacking the next check or whatever how
do pro skateboarders get their money
these days is it through competitions is
it through brand deals
brand deals bro for me it's personally
brand deals like i got crazy contracts
with like dgk i'm tied in with them
stray shoes we got dope deal with them
and it's just a monthly you know flat
rate what you're doing yeah and you get
royalties on top of like my signature
stuff you know my
name's on the shoe or my name's on my
board they give you you know whatever
deal you work out
then all the side deals you know i'm
assigned to img modeling so
you know i get that skateboard is just
my platform you know like i get a nice
little chunk just from skateboarding
then i'm able to
platform here and there you know we got
stizzy we got i was i was messing with
dtpg you know it's just like you're able
to yeah
raw deal
yeah
yo pop when we're talking about this we
gotta pop that tray up on the screen
that might be the dopest tray i've ever
seen i love it so much it's the coolest
[ __ ] trade design and how in the [ __ ]
didn't we think about that i have no
idea because i have rode the big tray
down to snow hill before mm-hmm and why
didn't i think about your make escape oh
[ __ ]
me and josh really worked really hard on
it love it
we went into detail bro it took forever
but
thank you man i hope you i hope you
enjoy it yeah i love it for you that
[ __ ]
yes dude i love it um so you said what
you're assigned to a modeling agency
right yeah yeah img man yeah cause i saw
you you because when i saw you the first
time this is a long [ __ ] time ago
before i knew ratchman knew you okay so
when i just saw you off of i think it
was raw's pace because i'm you know i
[ __ ] with josh we do a bunch of raw [ __ ]
um
i even thought like what is this full
always a skater because i saw the
clothes you were like oh he's like a
fashion kid or something so when i saw
you the other day i go oh it makes sense
because you did the met gala [ __ ] right
yeah uh what is it called
wait what was it where were you at the
other day i just saw you doing some
fashion [ __ ] the other day um
i did some [ __ ] with like coachella or
uh what was it the other day i didn't i
didn't go to that though i can't i don't
know that i don't know the name
of this [ __ ]
um
i don't know
oh yeah i went to a louis vuitton pop-up
they had yeah and i saw i saw you post
something about it go oh this makes
sense yeah yeah some fashion [ __ ] so now
that you're saying you're dying to
modeling [ __ ] makes perfect sense yeah
no it goes hand in hand because my page
isn't just all skateboarding it's
definitely like a lot of photos that's
what i was going to ask do they do
different like lifestyle photos or how
like what do they book you for aside
from like skateboard
oh just lifestyle honestly bro like
really just like
modeling gigs you know like real deal
[ __ ] yeah real deal [ __ ] like img got me
a deal with mateo honestly i'm not just
having this up here i really wanted a
motel but
you know just like dope deals like that
you know they look for people who like
[ __ ] with my image you know so i don't
really have to switch it up too much
the other day they got me a coach deal i
did a commercial for coach
a 2021 version for that all kids can
look up to like this model that you're
talking about
really is like you didn't our generation
didn't have people that could come up
and parlay brand deals oh no no i
couldn't bro it's like i almost like
i hate calling [ __ ] out like this and
that like stevie williams like there's
been a lot of like influencers in my
life that really like
chad muska terry kennedy like a lot of
these
jim greco ellington
these dudes who had like this [ __ ]
crazy style in skateboarding
and
tapped in with the hollywood and the new
york vibe you feel me that really like
did their [ __ ] but
i really like grad i gravitated to all
that and like
becoming a
professional skateboard i realized you
know like [ __ ] i like doing all types of
other [ __ ] yeah so like
in the new years of me doing my [ __ ] bro
i was
doing random deals with [ __ ] outside
skateboard companies
and posting this and that and loki
getting like hated on you know
past two three years bro like everyone
got those deals now you feel me
everyone's on this fashion tip man
they're
just killing it you know it just
collapsed collided it collided like no
other bro i remember talking to my homie
bad boy like
he seemed like i had a thrasher patch on
my mcn backpack
he's like damn bro like you are that
like fashion skateboard kid you feel me
like next you know that [ __ ] just took
off in the two next two years you know
like we got evan mott like perfect
example he's a model kid who's
skateboards and
he's another dude that just like paved
the way for a whole new generation you
know it's all possible do what you love
and if you go about it the right way
you could do it all you know you gotta
just
really be
strategic with with your plays and be
able to communicate with all your
sponsors and let them know what you got
going and what you want out of whatever
you're creating for yourself because
we're all like we're saying independent
contractors so
whatever you personally want make sure
you speak up on it because closed mouths
don't get fed at the end of the day i
love this you can you're not too cool
it's like yeah yeah can't be too cool
that never [ __ ] works bro
be cool but don't be too cool exactly
what you say you know but just be open
you know you if you got i like just
staying in neutral bro like never stop
it i'm not you know i'm like that like
growing picasso i was never
[ __ ] white enough coming out to la
for my first time i wasn't black enough
and it goes with i i'm not rich enough
for my rich [ __ ] i'm
i have too much money for my poor [ __ ]
like i'm always in the middle with [ __ ]
you feel me so
you gotta just be like this bro they
gonna love you love you i hate you yeah
just go to sleep
i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not letting no one be in my lane or
in my way too it's like it's like being
in traffic bro
you feel me you're driving you're in the
fast you're
supposed to be in the fast lane but you
got big ass diesel in front of you
but
you're just so comfortable you're like
[ __ ] it when you could easily like
tilt over it
and you got a whole [ __ ] lane in
front of you to take off and [ __ ] be
ahead of everyone you know or you could
just get caught up behind the door you
can just get caught that's being
comfortable that's being comfortable bro
but
[Music]
yeah take off once you hit that first
level of success it's easy to be like
okay i'm successful now but you could
fall off like you're lucky if you hit
that first level you're one person yes
exactly the one percenters of that one
percent stick around have a career the
only ones that do are the ones that work
hard yeah you got to have a sense of
desperation no matter what you're doing
always yeah
in direction you got to just send it
like have your own direction always you
know what you're doing you know what
you're doing for each
i know it sounds it's like some people
are like oh that's [ __ ] stupid your
jobs social media but no you don't
[ __ ] understand yeah how did you
watch tv today no but did you look at
your phone [ __ ] you then yeah exactly uh
you were looking at my job yeah you were
helping my job yes you were doing what i
was doing but you were doing it for free
and it's a different like it's a dif
people don't understand it you know it's
a different everyone plays their own
[ __ ] lane bro they don't understand
how many people you touch or how many
people you put on to certain [ __ ] that
they
wanted to know about you know it's like
this is a new generation bro people are
paying attention to other [ __ ] people
ain't watching tv no more people got
smart tvs i got nothing but apps like
netflix and hulu and youtube tv that
that's all they're watching and they're
jumping on tick tock
[ __ ]
youtube youtube
snapchat that's the new media bro if you
want to be updated you're looking at
your goddamn phone bro yeah so like what
i'm saying i look at your page
it's not just some
oh i've
done it's it's thought everything's
thought out like you're saying because
you're you don't want
coach to come look like this full just
posted 30 packs four days in a row i
don't think i could have called
you to me like that's all it was was
just packs and yeah you know what i mean
like i see the like you said when i look
at it see a fashion thing that's what i
said when i first saw like oh he's just
is he like skate skate and then i saw
the rest this year yeah because a lot of
people too that are like new fans of
mine they're about like
or just kids that are jumping my grand
they're like oh he's just another like
instagram skater or something you know
it's like because i had no idea i [ __ ]
with it yeah yeah i [ __ ] with you
already know like i [ __ ] with all the
fashion [ __ ] that i
love it yeah fashion brainless you know
you can always it it's growth you know
that's just it's got to be fun to get
booked for those gigs and just show up
you're just like
i look tight
it's crazy like
it's so funny it's crazy too i just got
booked for a movie we already filmed we
just got done filming it bro it's
colson machine gun kelly he hit me up
like
a month and a half ago i was like yo bro
i'm filming this movie
i've never been an actor ever in my life
i like it and it was game changing
pulling up to that set [ __ ] for a
month bro it was just like for a month
wow yeah bro every day shooting every
day besides the weekends we got the
weekends off
yeah i'll come home i'll get back to
long beach some nights like
four or five in the morning bro
but it's like it's really cool having
that whole experience and like all this
[ __ ] came from like being a skateboarder
you know they they said they wrote this
they wrote the script like a year two
ago and they had me in vision already
because the actor i am i played pretty
much myself and they had like a
skateboarder from long beach you know
homie that's just fried and just kicks
it
and he was gonna have someone else play
it and he like called me up like yo bro
like
let me send you the script like tell me
if you're down we start shooting in like
two days i'm like
[ __ ] like looked at the script i was
like oh i'm in bro like i'm down it was
very cool being that situation because
it was so new to me
that it was it was [ __ ] uncomfortable
you know and i haven't been
uncomfortable in a very long time and
like getting like getting the groove of
it and having them hit me with all this
criticism i was like it was good though
you know real big homie [ __ ] i was on
set with gada he's on like little dicky
show yeah dave yeah oh yeah dave shay
yeah
he he's a main actor in there so i had a
good bro
i had big bro really
helping me walk me through the steps and
just like being more comfortable being
me
it was cool just seeing like you know
how all this [ __ ] really goes down
shooting a movie and there's so much
pressure on you when you're the talent
and there's this such a huge operation
and then finally it's like all right go
yeah action and you're right
action you tell me that i found out
about it two days ago yeah but that's
the whole set knew that too you know
besides like
a couple of people but yeah but then
it's on the director to be able to know
how to handle that and to be able to
communicate in a way that gets you fired
up to do what you got to do they're very
everyone was very on point with
everything and i loved it you know it
it's a whole new bro
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah man
it's called um good morning with the u i
think it's gonna come out in like
february so
no
oh it's a [ __ ] real deal movie
it's not just an independent film no no
no yo that's tight as [ __ ]
i won't ask i won't ask any details on
here but
how'd you feel about conor mcgregor
taking off on uh machine gun that was
the [ __ ] literally what happened four
days after [ __ ] we wrapped up the
shoot bro like i texted i didn't even
hit him i just told him congratulations
he's like it's been hectic conor
mcgregor like swung at him or something
like that
yeah brother like threw a beer and said
something conor mcgregor will [ __ ]
swing at you no matter who you are wait
but he's a fighter you can't be doing
that that's what you would think how
many
close and so he's like six [ __ ] three
bro
yeah a couple weeks a couple weeks ago
uh i was driving through down here on
the street i just thought it was funny i
was going through and these people
blocked off the street i was like [ __ ]
you get out of the way and i drove
through i was smoking a joint and i felt
and i saw cameras i go no [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] up a shoe because i know what
it's like i know what it's like but it
was uh it was a machine and kelly's shoe
oh yeah and my son that's me that was
what we're shooting bro
right here
where was this right here it was uh it
was right here it's like burbank area
right san fernando yeah well we're out
we're everywhere bro bro that was that
was i was the [ __ ] driving through
the set wait was that night it was it
was like seven about to be nighttime oh
man that's crazy yeah my son directed
the whole movie bro you know that oh
that was for the movies
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro maybe i wasn't like on set no
because there was a dude with the
[ __ ] like dirt bike outfit and [ __ ]
yeah dude with a dirt bike outfit a kid
on a skateboard mod son had no shares oh
it's okay bro yeah and i'm like oh
my bad and i saw machine gun kelly and
then all these dudes with like big-ass
cameras like oh no yes but i [ __ ] up
that is hilarious yeah man that's even
better
what are the odds of this yeah we're
shooting everywhere yeah it was just
like a couple blocks away i saw it we
had so many different um scenes all
right it's [ __ ] hilarious yeah boy
small world made it better did they let
you get loose on the board and just like
oh i only skated once bro i was i did a
tray flip
and i'm in the movie i'm in a k-hole and
i'm dreaming about what i'm
you know i'm [ __ ] up and like when i'm
[ __ ] up the whole mod sounds like what
do you think he's dreaming about then it
goes to that vision if you don't look
like the truth skating and they're just
[ __ ] weak
this movie is a stoner movie slash like
it's
comedy off top probably one of the
funniest movies marissa and colton will
ever do
um a lot a little love in it then
stoner of course we're smoking we smoke
so much bro like it goes nuts nice yo
i
that's [ __ ] holy guys everyone in it
bro we got megan foxx amber oh see
because i told you i got saw machine gun
killing i think it was megan fox yeah
because i drove by and i just had a
joint i'm sorry guys
after i realized it was it was the
camera i went oh [ __ ] and i tried to get
through as fast as i could i mean it was
a street it's not my fault
but i was being a dick i was like nah
[ __ ] that i'm driving through yeah make
me go all the way around back to the
light [ __ ] you i just felt bad after
when i saw cameras i thought they were
just being dicks just blocking the
street yeah i'm sure they still got this
[ __ ] that is [ __ ] hilarious man so
that's gonna come out february yeah
february yeah that's huge man i bet you
with the personality that you seem like
you have like you probably learned so
much just working with people on a set
like that i know for me when i film on
set it's like i just learn by how
organized these like uh omar and i we're
talking about just about how organized
these [ __ ] people are how
professional they are they're
professionals they've got a whole team
too
everyone has their [ __ ] position
mommy jeremy he popped into it for a
minute he seemed like what was going on
and it's like
it's v you know we all been on sets like
that before you know but it's very you
want to be better yeah even mata and him
directing you know he goes from being
into character to [ __ ] taking control
speaking up and kind of being like i was
saying earlier being a [ __ ] but
professional about it you know just you
know don't take don't be don't switch
business up with friendship you know
it's like we here working bro yeah
very blank yeah i love that dude let's
be fired up for for your next one now
that you got one under your belt oh yeah
i did [ __ ]
that's big that's epic man yeah i'm
super excited that's very cool i i like
what you said about being uncomfortable
because i've only done one thing like a
tv or a commercial thing
but i was the guy
in the commercial
and when i got there and there was like
40 people in crane and rain machines and
like oh we're waiting on your ass
oh [ __ ] so i can't [ __ ] this up and i
felt like
when i'm about to go up and give a
presentation like in fifth grade but i
didn't do my my research
you know what i mean like that feel like
oh yeah i haven't felt so uncomfortable
because i'm always prepared for
everything
like you said like super high right
didn't you say you're like i'm always
funny but like extra
no i just wanted i smoked joints and
[ __ ] that was good
no but it is nervous but the thing you
said like it was being uncomfortable i
haven't been like so long i know that
feeling is like huh so
i guess i do need to learn a little more
like i feel like i guess i'm not on top
of my [ __ ] like i thought there's always
something to learn you know yeah and
then roll it back try to not be so i
went yeah yeah yeah exactly like hey man
and i know everybody's like this is the
high-ass kid right that's the high guy
holding up our shoe that's why i didn't
want to but i was just playing a drug
dealer so it was perfect
i was in character
see there'd be moments where i'm on set
and i know what i'm playing right now so
i'll be i'll just get super baked like
i'm actually high as [ __ ]
then it's like lights kevin actually i'm
like kind of hesitant i'm like oh wait
hold on hold on am i doing too much now
like
you know just get inside your own head
yeah but this is your first time doing
it you're prepared i feel like you're a
perfectionist yeah i was i was on point
what was it with everything too was it a
goal to do this before they booked you
for it like were you going after movies
well like i oh no i never went after
movies you know but i i shoot so many
commercials i kind of like directed
little skits with my filmer i'm like
very like into
creating content like you know i don't
want to
make content for other people for the
rest of my life you know unless i'm in a
movie so if i'm in front of a big screen
run that up let's go you know it's like
i've been in front of my homies all day
this is that's why i was so comfortable
doing it you know it's like
that [ __ ] just comes you know that's
what
what i'm saying like working grinding
something always comes you know like
another bag falls out
another another bag is all come within a
couple months you know it's like no
stress because i know the work ethic was
just bring something new you know it's
like that's how i've been my whole life
man it's like i never thought i'd be
here right now yeah but it's like
[ __ ] just levels up you know it's like
oh i went pro dope
i got my own skate shop dope
there is no finish line i got a pro
shoot dope like oh i got rolling tray i
got a new board like movie it's movie
like ads commercials like it just goes
you know it's that's me just working
hard and laying my steps you know like
speaking you don't have a i couldn't
even ask what are your goals because
it's not like well i don't know how i
feel tomorrow yeah like well maybe
tomorrow i'll go i need a billion
dollars not a hundred million like i
thought yeah exactly that to me is being
an entrepreneur yeah
that defines being an entrepreneur to me
yeah it's just like i don't even know i
just want to get to a point where i'm
like well i can take care of everyone
everybody needs to take care of it you
know i need to get to that point where
it's like all right cool
the house where could i work
not even that though but like work out
how [ __ ] invested into me how could i
invest into someone else because that's
i get that all the time people were like
yo could you invest in me like i'm like
invest in you like
you feel me or can you loan me like some
money it's like
there's no way i could possibly do that
you feel me i feel weird
giving my girlfriend money feeling the
only people i give money to willing to
is my mom or anyone in my direct
immediate family you feel me anytime you
need something you call me boom here you
go apple pay whatever
but like anything else it's like
that's out the out the pocket because
i'm not there yet and once i'm there
then i got you because i'm already nice
bro i'll give whatever i'll give anyone
anything i don't care unless it's like
sentimental to me you know yeah but for
the most part
hey bro you my dog
i'm no higher than you
you know we're right here you feel me i
don't want any of my people to feel like
i'm here you feel me because one day if
i all this [ __ ] did disappear and i did
have nothing i don't want [ __ ] to look
at me like oh this [ __ ] thought he was
[ __ ]
way up here now look at him you feel me
it's like
i'll lose everything today and you were
like oh
yeah you know like everyone goes through
the step but you can't like overstep
like
just higher power [ __ ] you feel me
of course yeah hell yeah i mean that's
just being authentic
yeah
what's the what's the path for young
kids coming up wanting to be pro skaters
in 2022
man just
you know it's it's just working hard and
you know being a pro nowadays i think
your anyone could be pro bro like
not bro how can someone
do you because bro we don't meet a lot
of people what everything you've been
saying about work is exactly how why me
and my work together yeah i've never met
anybody else that works as hard as it's
full and i'm like oh so you're gonna
stay 24 hours let's do it all night
let's [ __ ] get it let's do if we has
to be off tomorrow it has to be off
there's not a lot of people and it's
like yo we'll do it tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow the next day too for the rest
of my [ __ ] life if i
had a lot of successful people on the
show and nobody's ever come on on just
one person attitude though yeah nobody
that's came on
i'm on the grind bro like you feel me
it's it's nothing stopping me it's like
i
god got me you know when you know you're
good you know when you're driving
sometimes you were like whoa like i
don't feel so good or even i get that
sometimes but
you know when you know you're good like
no matter what every day we're gonna be
good yeah don't check the back
i'm not gonna [ __ ] up they might yeah i
don't know
if i do my my angels or my energy
whoever is looking down at me right now
that we get you feel me and that's how i
look at every day bro you gotta wake up
and get it bro because tomorrow i could
be gone but i want all my people to know
if i would die tomorrow boujee lived his
[ __ ] life he he's good you know he's
i know like even after life is good bro
we all this is all energy bro we just
here you know so that's why i try like
lead by example practice what you preach
and
hopefully you're preaching love
positivity and peace because
that's all we really got bro you feel me
you know you don't want to go down like
i think it was
yeah that's your favorite one everybody
be like man this is not good you're not
like well it's full oh it's still full
of me 30 bucks you know they followed me
30 dollars in these bed
every [ __ ] day
it was a couch i tried to go down like
nipsey bro
that's his favorite person of all time
bro he's a
philosopher and just like you go you
watch old
high eight clips of that fool and he's
always preaching like about the
community and like lifting his [ __ ] up
and
kept it real classic i always had a fly
chain on but always had like dickies and
some you feel me chuck taylor's on kept
it real
real simple he inspired me to want to
deliberately inspire people
like he that was his message
you know like if you can if you have
nothing else if you can inspire other
people that that's why that's cool like
when you asked about like the fan bases
i feel like his fan base was the only
was one that was like similar to yours
in how organic it was
that's why he could do the proud to pay
that's why people paid a hundred dollars
for a free cd and he sold hundreds of
thousands of them because he had that
fan base he had that connection you
understood
what the same thing like you have to be
you have to give back to the fans the
way you do it is by giving game like
this and yeah once you start dropping
like
letting people know that there is a
little path you can follow yeah i am
into that bro you brought that down
smooth bro like that's what it is bro
and that's why you feel me like i don't
want to say [ __ ] but man my dm's like
when i post like because that's why bro
on my instagram like on my bottom like
little stories you could save and [ __ ]
your favorites like it's all just like
love love is like
all my fans that ever tagged me in
stories that i've seen and reposted you
feel me you click on that and you'll
find all you know whoever tagged me and
anyone anyone that like purchased the
board or anything of my signature [ __ ]
then i got quotes
and i just got so many quotes that are
just
letting people know you know what what's
really out there and like the the vision
you should follow instead of just on
some [ __ ] you know
and the people that respond to these
quotes brought him and say and it's
crazy like how many people
would just like reach out and be stoked
on like
you posting that and just like letting
them see that you know because sometimes
i even post [ __ ] that doesn't really
reflect to me that day but i know it's
going to touch someone and they do they
oh someone always hits me bro like damn
i needed this today you feel me yeah and
that's what gets gets me stoked you feel
me because
bro p you need something
from like your even if i'm not your idol
or like you know someone that's like got
that following base
practice what you preach bro you feel me
get give it to the world let them know
what's really out there you know because
there is like this weird little secret
in life where it's like
if you know how to swindle and finesse
like you could cut all these [ __ ]
lanes that people think you need to
stand in
to succeed you know you gotta just find
that lane and like
see it and just [ __ ] climb your way
to the top without like all the [ __ ]
that you think you have to go through
yeah that's that's that's true but
sometimes yeah you can't avoid it's
unavoidable sometimes and that's okay
though you guys yeah you know check it
as it comes but still be on that grind
as long as you can connect with people
you can really do whatever you want
before people didn't have that option
when didn't have social media you had to
go through the record industry to get
into music yeah you know but if you can
build up a fan base of people that care
about what you have to say that's the
whole point these big companies all they
want
you know what's up yeah
that's true
so
hey what's up guys i just wanted to take
a moment to say thank you to one of our
sponsors this is on it o-n-n-i-t human
optimization if you guys been following
for a while you know we are fully
sponsored by on it you may have seen on
the joe rogan podcast many other
podcasts as you guys know i've been
trying to change my lifestyle yes i do
all this stuff but i'm trying to lose
weight for my health for myself i'm not
going to stay young forever i need to
take care of it human optimization this
is the perfect episode boo johnson like
you said i treat my body like a car it
needs maintenance i've been running it
into the ground i need to upkeep right
now if you want to check it out go to
onit.com onnit dot com forward slash
yola and that code will get you 10 off
at checkout on every single thing except
for the weights on it is a perfect way
to upkeep your body they have a
subscription box it shows up at your
door same time every single month so you
don't forget to be healthy i do it all
the time we go grocery shopping and what
do we do right after oh let's get fast
food or cruise we have to you know cook
real quick you know we're so tired from
we all do it but sometimes you have to
discipline yourself so this is the
perfect episode perfect guess for us to
talk about this so all gear all
supplements all protein powders all
shroom tech alpha brain everything else
and the clothes to make it easy no
matter where you're listening to spotify
apple or you're watching on youtube in
the video description on it link will be
there that's the link with the discount
code already added just check out the
website all right just check out on
it.com remember that onnit.com
forward slash yolo that gets you 10 off
of everything except for the weights as
we always say guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands to support us on
it is a sponsorship we've had and we're
going to have for a long time so thank
you guys for actually using the code
click the link in description it really
helps us out it helps them out and
everybody wins
just want to say a special shout out to
manscape for being one of the sponsors
for this episode and you already know
we've been with manscape since almost
the beginning of the show shout out to
them for sponsoring our explicit ass
podcast guys real quick before i even
start
forward www.manscape.comforward yola
that is 20 off plus free shipping brand
new to manscape this is the performance
package 4.0 yes is a real product spall
deodorant ball toner and yes there's a
nose hair trimmer and the weed whacker
that's for your dick and over here to my
left your right this is the ball crop
mops these are ball wipes you swipe your
balls off with this and for everyone out
there in other countries that have been
trying to order manscape but haven't
they just updated their global shipping
they now ship to almost every single
country in the world two million
customers can't be wrong and definitely
four million balls can't be wrong yes
there's razors to straight razors but if
you're using a straight razor on your
dick you're a [ __ ] assassin no more
straight razors no more razors go to
manscape this the weed whacker 4.0 this
is
wireless chargeable waterproof has a
[ __ ] light on it as we said before
this is technology updated this is the
cell phone for your dick go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yolo that
is 20 off plus free shipping get your
dick right
so thank you guys so much for listening
to our podcast about dick jokes and all
that stuff i really appreciate it as i
always say thank you so much for
supporting the brand to support us back
to the episode
let me ask
uh what was the first time because i
know i remember
you you're skating you're doing all this
[ __ ] the people you're getting bored you
know new trucks oh thanks new wheels
sponsorship this is
do you remember the first time a company
was like yo we want to pay you to smoke
cars [ __ ]
oh yeah
honestly like do you remember that day
because you know it was a [ __ ]
hilarious day to you because you left
with you know they gave me free weed and
they want me to just post it honestly
like
i don't know bro people have been giving
me free weed for a while but when it
really hit me like i'm getting paid to
[ __ ] represent weed yeah that's when
i got signed by weed maps bro oh no [ __ ]
2017
you feel me they started a whole like
extreme sports squad and that's when i
like really got put on bro that's when i
first saw your page yeah because they
were gonna do uh like a tv network with
shows and i filmed the first episode of
my show okay at the irvine at the irvine
one on that long at 42 irvine or some
[ __ ] as far as [ __ ] that one they had so
many dope ass [ __ ] rooms sick ass
stupid you've never seen the studio in
there yeah big ass studios with glass
wall for the producers
bro they had some sticks they had a lot
of [ __ ] going but yeah that's when i
signed a crate so i got dropped by
mountain dew like
prior to that a couple of months prior
so yes i'm about to do for skating yeah
i was i was assigned to them
with them
that's why i like met lil wayne for my
first time i went to new orleans skated
with him and [ __ ] it was cool that's ty
can that full connective skater now yeah
no he's in it yeah he's in it's a winner
bro he's been skating for so long now i
remember and he still is shredding you
know he's just progressing and doing his
thing he loves it honestly good [ __ ]
it's dope seeing him
but uh yeah so they dropped me for like
my whole image like i was smoking weed
they're like consistently telling me
like yo like chill i'm posting all that
listen you know me i'm
i'm blue jay bro i'm big smoking like
that's that's just part of my whole
image and what i do you know like i grew
up on that [ __ ]
and yeah they dropped me sadly you know
then
we maps they started up this team and
like i was the first dude or
i think i was like first or second dude
they hit up like yo we heard about
mountain dew
we try and put you on and like
talk about this and
go crazy pretty much went in there had a
crazy meeting with them that's hilarious
and that was like the thing you feel me
like [ __ ] turn that [ __ ] around real
quick that goes back to like something
always comes you know it's like you
stick to your roots it's it's
it's something's bound to happen yeah
just stay real genuine and keep working
so that's why i was like damn bro like
universal i'm tied into this [ __ ] now
like
now you're getting paid to be [ __ ]
the face of weed which is
that's why i wanted to ask like how what
a crazy feeling right yeah it's crazy
right yeah man even like wow really even
just [ __ ] with raw too like back in
the day you know
boxes of raw papers i'm like damn bro
this is like
this is legendary i used to buy raw
paper
and like first time i talked to josh and
dale and all those fools
yeah so like having to deal with them
and just that relationship that's
another one where it's like damn all
right we're in the wii game can you put
your mic down a little bit towards you
just like angle it towards you yeah cool
that's when i was like damn yeah we're
in the wii game for sure you know we
tied in and you know i like popping up
to all the events and smoke outs and
just being in the community instead of
just like taking you know yeah going and
actually seeing what this is about yeah
who's building up those brands exactly i
mean those are the people that are
buying that [ __ ] yeah that make it
popular
all these homies like
and it's cool bro like i respect it it's
a whole hustle that's like even if
you're in it legally
it's even more of a hustle bro you feel
me and like you really gotta you gotta
make your brand survive yeah his first
ten years of legalization we'll see who
the [ __ ] survives yeah that's what it's
about it's really it's amazing it's it
is it is you can't be like we're the
biggest because then what's next here
yeah
you gotta build you have to a ten-year
plan it can't be like what are we doing
this month
yeah
you gotta be
six six months a year ahead of all that
[ __ ] yeah so so you you uh
i see you once dizzy like doing modeling
[ __ ] for them too and you're sponsored
by them what's going on with that yeah i
gotta deal with them uh under athlete
though so they got like their um
what is it called
influence squad but we got like the
influence skater team you know it's like
me
derek wilson
um david lloyd
mikey mikey jones you know we got a
little squad that
you know we just
they hook us up take care of us
and we just
make little edits this and that
um
to i'm trying yeah it's a real just
lifestyle you know because that's where
sizzy capitalized on they're really they
killed it with the their whole um
marketing scheme and how they go about
[ __ ] and they also got amazing products
so you just put on for like
for them in the streets and you know
rock their clothes smoke their weed and
just spread the word
so again being paid
to smoke weed yeah
which is such a way yeah man you got
you're on your way to being
like you said comfortable
yeah you have so many avenues because
you you know you have you you have to it
can't be one thing nah bruh if it's one
thing it's over what if your knee was
worse oh i i'm just sitting here yeah i
mean but no no don't worry i'm just
gonna do the movie i got to shop
you have to have a couple lanes man
it's a seven
forms of income streams of income is the
average millionaire yeah seven streams
yeah i think i'm i'm getting there yeah
you're almost there right yeah and now
it's a goal yeah little goals right yeah
little goals to get there no rush though
man like i'm here to pay my dues and
work hard for every penny man yeah
so it's a journey man it's a beautiful
journey i always say to like my friends
and my family like life's a beautiful
struggle
it's lip quality
so uh the brand just have fun yeah bro
what's going on when did you start this
so just have fun bro this is a crew that
like started in chatroom when i was it
like actually my partner from your
hometown all right yeah the tattoo bro
jhs attached me
but my partner
we'll get into that
he
um he pretty much made the logo because
we got a logo you feel me this is the
slogan we got a logo as well what's the
logo marty can you look it up huh he's
already on it yeah so the logo is cool
and that's where
it was just like a brand it was
something that you know we grew up in a
small town you feel me we didn't have
the whole town didn't have much so
we'll have like homies come through
hungarians will be breaking boards this
and that
and we kept it module you feel me just
just have fun you know now that was our
crew you know we'll write in school
books this and that just oh no [ __ ]
the town thought it was like a gang
this and that you know was like positive
[ __ ] logo yeah that's the logo right
there so i'll zoom in on that what is it
it's got the skateboard going through
the j and the h here oh
oh damn my necklace is going backwards
this whole time that's [ __ ] up
i love that oh i see it
here's the chain right oh [ __ ]
the skateboard
bro that is a great logo
so yeah man we started that um
it's got the f hidden in there too
though oh i see it
the wheel by the truck it's been there
for generations bro then when i went pro
you feel me i was like damn man like i'm
trying to start my own [ __ ] like
something just
not nothing to make a bunch of money off
of but just i wanted i you know it's
that time you know i was like 21 22.
i need to start my own [ __ ] bro sat down
with my homie justin williams
going through for weeks bro trying to
think of like names just random names
and like i came down to it like
you know what like i got i've had the
tattoo forever and i was like bro
jeff you feel me this is it you feel me
like
what am i doing yeah and we practice
that was right
so we pressed play on it then like i
started making hats this and that
then my ex-partner
can he see what i was doing you feel me
he's like oh [ __ ] you know because he
did he was like ex-partner in what um
jhf so like i'll get into that oh but
it was just weird you know like he seen
how i was doing it and he's like yo
because he made the logo and we you know
that's always been a logo i didn't
really
think about having a partner in that you
know because you know it's always
something
he came at me like yo bro like i kind of
need in that you know that's my logo i
created that so and so i was like oh
[ __ ] it you know he was working at one
of those skate companies i was skating
for anyways so it kind of made sense he
was like he's been in the industry
so we boom jumped it off bro
um
long story short we [ __ ]
started doing our jhf [ __ ] you know like
it was in every stores doing its thing
and
i kind of got [ __ ] over and jhf went
on to pause
just because on some bad business too
you know me i'm very professional i like
hey my everything got to be on books and
that wasn't his tip so i went on pause
for like two years
then the past year i kind of rebirthed
it you know i got a lawyer
nice i had to kick everyone out got my
own [ __ ]
redid the llc
got the trademark i was like all right
let me like restart and get this [ __ ]
going you feel me
and yeah it's been like going ever since
and it's more like a it's more of a
motto than just like pushing out clothes
you know it's a message to let kids know
no matter what you're doing
skateboarding biking playing football
you feel me playing tennis whatever it
is bro make sure you have fun with it
and just follow your passion and do what
you love you know because if if it's not
what you love you're not having fun with
it you know yeah you're going to work
angry you're doing this and that i wake
up every morning happy blessed
filled with joy and like ready to have
fun and experience whatever's
coming to me in life
so
that's my company bro just have fun
brother and like we're putting on i want
everyone else to like yeah it's
something everybody can relate to yeah
like have a dope ass day i mean exactly
mm-hmm a little slogan fridays we'll be
doing a little events and [ __ ]
where's is it's a store i didn't even
roll that joint
it's a store
um no no no um but it's in pharmacy
board shop like the game oh god she got
you so where can everybody find that at
in long beach yeah in long beach i did
this three three three pines three three
three yeah oh it was a great sign great
sign great [ __ ] building avenue
then on my store jhfstore.com
it's just jj hf store yeah jhf stuff we
just dropped a new line like two days
ago too
nice good [ __ ] yeah bro
there goes right there
yeah you can read that later i love that
little i wrote like a whole little
caption about like jhf and lifestyle
good [ __ ]
meaning means to me you feel me i mean
you put it perfectly right now bro
i mean like i like i said i love the
message bro thank you i did i i you know
i've been i've been a few times
i'm down i'm down like i said we got you
gear over here but
yeah i want to check that show that's i
love the message thank you bro it's good
it's good and like i said we've had many
guests on
uh that's exactly what's about to ask
don't look don't look
don't look at the screen don't look at
the screen oh i thought you looked at
the screen my bad all right that's
exactly what i was about to ask marty
i can say
um that's my brother jeremy that's my
photographer he'd be killing [ __ ]
i didn't know it i because i had the
headphones i didn't know anybody else
was there yeah and i scared the [ __ ] out
and went oh [ __ ] there was two other
heads and scared them
i didn't say anything though but we like
it scared the [ __ ] they'd be lurking
i got the gang guys yo um we have a
little segment right here all right it's
called who were you in the 90s
yep so i'm going to ask you a question
give you two options you pick the
options
and that's it i bet you ready yeah
vh1 or mtv
mtv
this is you in the 90s yep you have to
think about yourself and in the 90s
no you know what i'm saying like who
were you he was born in the 90s yeah
he's born so it's perfect
he's probably he's only four years
younger than me we've done this many
times yeah adam sandler jim carrey
um
the hesitation is like okay i'm saying i
love sandler you feel me like longest
yards and [ __ ] like
that's my [ __ ] but jim k cash he's
hilarious
he is all that's comedy bro
um
what's that movie called the um
the mass liar liar ancient terror
detective yeah
my kids just saw the scene where he's
crawling out of the rhino's ass
yo as a kid that's your father like the
master's
[ __ ]
bro like as a kid are you kidding me i
just rewatched it again a couple weeks
ago it's still just as good as special
effects are better than any movie now
it's perfect how'd they do that i don't
know that full dorian
spitting those bullets back
it gets me every time man
the mask is a [ __ ] reference we bring
up in this second dude who puts a mask
on my [ __ ] they made him just like
ugliest that's what i'm talking about
yeah i'm like damn you look like a
monster yeah yeah yeah this is like this
has come up we talk about the mask a lot
on this show
why it always does it always [ __ ]
happens it's a great movie it's a
classic bro it's like minutes in society
bro and it's a society yeah there's
always there's always just you fear
right once you get a podcast
i say everything you're saying it's like
yo it sounds like our solo podcast
that's like on the stage
are you ready tupac or biggie smalls not
as a person as musical artists um
just the music nothing behind it
probably biggie same like
i i love pog like because he gets so
lyrical and i love his poetry
i think biggie's just like his energy
like if i had to play some [ __ ] i'm
playing biggie just like
like he really had the whole
brooklyn cracking like he really
that's how i feel too i love tupac
of course how can you not
he's really he's so spot so sweet too
like man you watch interviews of him
he's just like the realest but you said
music or not person like if we had to go
with the person that inspires you the
most tupac he's a different
he's not just a rapper i feel like he's
on po he's a mother of a poet that
[ __ ] in baller ass movies he's
a good actor it's there's more than just
that but big smile i mean the 10
characters
he was just so he was just like spilling
out of him he had to get like yeah he
could not be him such a big personality
was cool
he was a rapper tupac was just like i
care he was okay yeah as a person that's
why i had to specify it yeah because
it's a no-brainer if i just don't say
that true i don't know if biggie would
have had a juice in them though
yeah
no
it's just so saying emily was a good
actor dude i was a good [ __ ] actor
man
i just realized those folks were like 24
or 24 they were kids they're kids man
i think about me at 24.
i was filming packs
having fun watching the office that's
that legendary by that age oh yeah
without like social media in this yeah
yeah because if you got famous and
anywhere before social media you were
[ __ ] famous
imagine how like lit it was though to be
like a movie star and like
[ __ ] imagine being jack [ __ ] in the
80s oh my god oh [ __ ] presidential
treasure
everywhere you go
like and everything's like way more
under you're able to get away with a lot
yeah there's no cell phones man people
doing lines off each other jets without
[ __ ] any security like man oh before
social media
life was [ __ ] cool
for that kind of stuff yeah
but i don't know man that killed a lot
of things bro it did but it opened up a
lot of doors for people
smaller doors then it helps more people
not just the ones but
that's jack nicholson in the 80s who
doesn't want to be here
oh yeah sorry ready step by step or
family matters
family matters for you
okay yeah for me same
pulp fiction or forrest gump
uh
[ __ ] poke fishing poke fiction that's my
one of my favorite movies ever
same with him all right you ready for
his game's amazing night it's so good
i just watched it again the other day
yeah it's my favorite movie because it's
a guess well that truman show you've
seen trump show yeah [ __ ] yeah bro but
not a good [ __ ] movie that's it's
crazy that's when you know that jim
carrey is a good [ __ ] hacker
he goes from valencia
man from the mass to truman show that's
some [ __ ] contrast man here we go you
remember it pennywise the old one or
chucky
wait it
you remember it oh the old old one those
ones were [ __ ] up uh with tim curry
chucky i i was more on chucky though
that's just scary in the 90s let's just
get the [ __ ] out of here don't do it i
want [ __ ] don't do it he has a sound
board on there [ __ ] that
all right mario
hell no mario donkey kong
oh man probably mario brother same
here we go full house are saved by the
bell
yeah
mcdonald's a burger king in the 90s
though
as a kid as a kid i would say burger
king brother the um fries the chicken
fries are so fire oh i was more talking
about the toys that you get yeah that's
all i was like mcdonald's was like i
know it did
they always had they had space jam so
that's why i would like i picked
mcdonald's as a kid if i was a kid i
[ __ ] kicked for some reason
all right here we go michael jackson or
michael jordan
uh
i was definitely more of a like michael
jackson fan then i wasn't into
basketball like that but
[ __ ] like all i did was space jam other
than that i didn't watch basketball so
michael jackson for me too michael
jackson was sick but space yeah the
[ __ ]
oh yeah it's face jam i love that movie
and the car that's the cartoon one right
yeah special moment jordan yeah uh here
we go boys in the hunter madness of
society
five boys
i love men's society it was a it's a
hard one yeah that's not real it's a
horror but the more legendary back to
back yeah that's like good fellows at
casino but ah don't be able to exactly
don't ask me that [ __ ] that's exactly
what it is right like damn how are you
gonna say that [ __ ] here we go
you you change this okay you changed who
did we have that we switching around
this [ __ ] switched the [ __ ]
again
this is and this is any error it says
thorn soda or chocolate milk
[ __ ] we have that today no
listen orange soda was orange soda in
the [ __ ] 90s
yeah okay i definitely do orange soda
all right i love that all right
you guys are right
i'm wrong yoo-hoo
you had options no it's just friends
get out of here
you were fired bro my homie brad put me
on those yo if you had those as a kid
you were bawling yeah no my husband oh
god he got them yeah
yeah that's when you know your friend
both their parents had a job if they had
you who's in the fridge oh [ __ ] well
yeah the first time i ever saw somebody
with snacks i was shocked
because mercedes i tried to keep my [ __ ]
stacked now hell yeah the first time you
got out had money yeah i said
uh one last question
you feel those mushrooms yet
yeah
but it's just like you feel me it's like
it's it's a slight bro i like just
having that
way shout out to my boy he's like i got
you bro
he's like damn we should have took
mushrooms i was like what
i'm down should i have my show you drop
me someone something down he's like now
i got some right here
it's like perfect little stem just like
you know for that little feeling yeah
i like my doesn't bro like i tried it
for the first time this year oh yeah
i liked it yeah i uh i took like a gram
and a half and went to the dodger game
and it was really cool yeah it was gross
man it's like it's you know
it's like almost like medicine
you know i've done a lot of
hallucinogenic drugs and shrooms is
definitely one i could do like
consistently yeah that's the one
i just gotta have i usually take the
i usually like a quarter but i s but i
only like i don't go go do crazy [ __ ]
yeah
cool
no no music no lights
your dumb mushrooms in the dark
nah usually with people or i have like
look at the stars or something like by
the ocean room in your room
with no lights on the music
that's the craziest [ __ ] i ever did in
my life
right there no it's fun everything you
think of it's like a projector out of
your eye you can see it
because it's so black it's like you have
your eyes closed
so you don't know if your eyes are
closed or not
colors you see so much [ __ ]
see i'm [ __ ] slipping man i got i ate
the [ __ ] eighth of the shrooms
nothing yeah they didn't hit it
don't worry i will find some [ __ ] that
you're going oh [ __ ] this is what
mushrooms are but yep i'll see you in a
couple hours we've only had one guest
compare psychedelics goblin got on here
and just comparing acid and mushrooms
[ __ ] acid and [ __ ] yeah but i never
really [ __ ] with acid i've never tried
it i don't actually bro that's just uh
strums is more like groovy you feel me
you're like
you're actually able to like just like
reid's cousin like it's like yeah i
would imagine seeing things like kind of
cool you know unless you take like a
[ __ ] quarter or like a straight
eighth like i could take eighth and be
like tripping but i don't like tripping
like that i like just feeling like yeah
that easy go you know just like a dose
with acid bro it's like everything's so
intense you can't be around certain
people you definitely want to be like in
an open open zone where it's like
because you're going to be seeing [ __ ]
breathe bro you're seeing the plants
breathe everything's fine yeah right
that sounds fun it's life bro it's
but it's a lot you know it lasts for
[ __ ]
six to nine hours so you're just [ __ ]
cooking you know are you over it by the
time it's done yeah you're drained bro
because it takes time you go through
[ __ ] waves you
be stoked you'll be happy you [ __ ]
start crying talking to your
deep into conversations you know then it
kind of goes down
you feel me i've done dmc bro and that's
like you [ __ ] dmt too right yeah i've
done it once bro
it was life-changing honestly and
[ __ ] changed my life it was just like
opened my life to or opened my like
meaning in life to a higher projector
and knowing like we're talking about
earlier like i'm good bro you feel me
like no matter what at the end of the
day i know i'm good because i should
open my eyes just so much [ __ ] bro like
the first like
the first like when i just like fell out
i was like breathing you feel me just
eyes closed
like that's all i did for like 10
minutes bro when i was out
i felt like a jellyfish and like
i felt like just a pulse but before i
got to that post actually let me pause
like
it was a [ __ ] like battle between me
and like everything around me like
wait who did i just do this with was
that crack who what the [ __ ] was that
like
do i need to call my mom like
i need to tell my girl like
like where the [ __ ] am i you feel me
inside it came to this conclusion where
it's like
i am i i'm the only like
person who could call any shots in my
life
and that's when
i blasted off bro it was so crazy what
did you see it was just it was
everything bro shapes colors
like
i just i honestly that's where i go back
to like uh being a pulse just like
it was it was weird bro like and me
breathing
kind of like made me feel like that you
know and it took i just seen all types
of [ __ ] bro the life of flowers just
[ __ ]
every weird thing possible you know but
and i was laughing throughout my journey
like i felt me like
it was just weird bro like it's almost
it's so hard to explain but it was so
beautiful and you come you come back
completely normal you're fully
capable of
doing whatever and it's the highest
[ __ ] like
takeoff you ever like feel but it's the
most naturalist drug it's so weird your
eyes closed the whole time yeah my eyes
are closed the whole time just
if you were to open your eyes would you
i almost couldn't bro and like when it
when everything was ending i was like
breathing
slower and like it was so weird bro i
sound like i sound so crazy but
it's like all everything that what i was
like
in
just like came straight down to my
[ __ ] third eye bro and like
like as i was opening my eyes i just
seen
every like
shape of the life of the flower of life
you feel me it was just so insane and
like i just woke up so [ __ ] juice and
i like got up i hugged my homie bro i
was like bro thank you so much like
because we had like a deep conversation
before and he just offered it to me i
was gonna say did you do anything to get
prepared for it because i've seen videos
that have people it go south for them
yeah dmg is something that you have to
be gifted to bro you don't just like go
out there and [ __ ] buy it and [ __ ]
just hit it you feel me like and he's
just like bro we got deep conversations
like oh hey you want to do like some dmt
i was like
i kind of need that right now you know i
kind of i've heard about you know i've
done my research i like i understood it
you know i've done my [ __ ] asses shrooms
i was alright yeah i'm down [ __ ] he
lives in the penthouse bro downtown la
50th floor bro he had an extra room his
house is super like dope it's all modern
[ __ ] big-ass crystals everywhere
he's the one who did like my mandela's
and [ __ ] oh he tattooed you oh yeah
right after we did my feet bro he's done
all types of tattoos on me bro
you got tattooed right after your dmt
trap yeah bro that's how like organic it
is bro
and he set me up he put me in the guest
room he had a nice little [ __ ] guest
bed that's what he's doing
yeah brother threw some zen music on
just um
yo this fool sounds so cool
bro
i got so stuck in your story man i've
been i've been [ __ ] that was crazy
he set me up
told me what you're doing just
as i'm blowing out bro it's just like
i swear to god bro it's like [ __ ] no
no you hit three
i hit it three times i was like
oh in the same breath
no the no two times actually oh go down
and you like start getting that like
[Music]
then i hit it again he packed it a
little bit more on it as i was hitting
it bro that's all i remember
holding as long as you can bro
right there like
how long was the moment before you took
off like oh bro you as you're blowing it
out you're just you're i'm i'm like
slowly like because you're in control
you know you're like no
and i had no choice though but to just
like slowly just lay back as i'm blowing
it out
and you're just out bro like you you
that's why they call it you bla you
blast off because you literally like you
sit down then i swear god bro you go
through i think everyone goes to this
stage where it's like
who the [ __ ] are you
are you even able to [ __ ]
take control of this and take off you
feel me and that's where i was at first
and
right when i was like
how am i thinking about this [ __ ] like
i'm good i'm good you feel me like do
you think it's because you've done
psychedelics before that you're able to
navigate that i think so yeah maybe not
though i think i'm just like
strong-minded
if i need something or want something
i'm very like outspoken and maybe though
because even when i've done
crazy drugs where i'm just like you feel
me i've never been that person who's
gonna act a fool outside like once i
feel like i'm getting to that point i'm
out bro yeah like you feel me i've done
you know [ __ ] molly and [ __ ]
press pills but i'm just like my eyes
are [ __ ]
twitching i'm just like i need to get
the [ __ ] out of here you know and that
that's something that
probably puts me on a higher level where
it's like
you know i was able to [ __ ]
like breathe it through and like
understand it
because it was nuts bro i swear to god
like it's so hard to explain but
ever since then brother i've i've always
been on like a cool groovy level but
after that i'm like
you feel me i'm good you feel me i'm
gonna send you this joe rogan interview
and he talks about just about dmt bro he
tells you the
full breakdown kind of like how i would
but just in joe rogan's level and it's
nuts bro you're like oh my god bro you
feel me it's
it's something that's right there people
do all this crazy smoked cigs and drink
alcohol and
do all this crazy [ __ ] but there's this
little drug out there it's already in
your brain it's already there bro you
feel me and you have all these crazy
dreams people dream every night wake up
like oh [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
tripping
you know what was that
damn two trip that's a dmt triple you
hit dmc it's a whole nother [ __ ]
planet bro like
it's a good understanding of life
but i don't
say anyone go just do that like i was
saying it needs to be blessed to you
it needs to be the moment you know it's
like
i was 27 you know it's like i'm i'm
once you 25 year grown man you can make
your own [ __ ] decisions you know and
i was like you know do you feel like you
need to do it again
oh bro that's like
once in a couple years when you really
need it like i'm it's been like two like
at least two years i'm cool
i'm
i'm blessed you feel i'm still able to
tell you the story and have that energy
when i'm telling you like yo this shit's
powerful and it's beautiful but don't
just go out there and [ __ ] do dmg you
know because there are [ __ ]
they got dmt pins that forces yeah my
homie
with me and he's like i have to leave
this pen here in my eyes like text me
it's dmt pen that
[ __ ] good good thing you said some [ __ ]
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] like you want
it to be you you imagine ripping it
down in my house
it's just zoned out like
and with your eyes open you just don't
know you're not in the could you imagine
that that would [ __ ] suck that was uh
so was it like five ten minutes
yeah i was out for at least like five
ten minutes it felt like a lifetime i
just felt it felt like a very long time
bro but i was like
it was weird it like timed it out you
know it knows what it's doing yeah yeah
yeah it's so weird the way rogan
explains it it's like it's meant to kind
of interface with your brain like
they go together you know like it's kind
of like a design i don't [ __ ] i've
never done any psychedelics yeah i gave
him the first mushrooms and didn't
didn't work for him which is the crazy
thing he like understand it like though
you like you get it you know you're like
open to
understanding it but it's just all
psychedelics but it's a it's a trip you
know it's just your own your everyone's
different but we're all the same so if
you're on that if you're on that level
like
it's going to work beneficial for you
yeah especially if you don't abuse it
you know really
say don't you gotta say a prayer but you
know sit down and like put that energy
into something when you're doing it you
know like i so you know you're gonna
trip like you know just a little priest
like i'm taking this
mushroom i'm
i know i'm willing to
see some
things i might not be comfortable with
i'm gonna feel weird
and this is what it is
you know and take it like just enjoy it
you know and that's to try to grow from
it basically yeah like
yeah exactly
psychedelic advice from john so
[ __ ] a lot different than [ __ ]
goblins a lot different from joshua
joshua with me we ate mushrooms on the
first episode oh yeah and uh
uh and uh he eats mushrooms on his
podcast but a lot it's called high live
so that's the point he gets [ __ ] up
he's a community he's funny as [ __ ]
you just explained that so well for
anybody out there i'm gonna that's a
clip right there that was great that was
the best advice i feel like a lot of
people wonder about you
but not a lot of people actually like
have access to it or in a safe way
that's good i'm talking about anything
like that advice just knowing what
you're getting into talking to
yourselves
because if you're talking to somebody
you go well i'm too scared then don't
[ __ ] do it have a prayer if you're
over here asking your homie hey man like
what do you think about this like
hey bro
if you feel comfortable run it up bro if
you don't feel like it's your time it's
all right don't run it because that's
when you [ __ ] up yeah that's when [ __ ]
goes south bro i haven't had a bad one
so yeah likewise bro always just keep it
cool yeah keep it cool put good energy
into it and just you know i feel like
you want to probably have your ducks
it's kind of a weird thing because then
one side of me would be like you
probably want to have your [ __ ] together
and be in a really great space when you
go test that out yes but at another
point it's like you might need it most
when you're at a really bad place in
life yeah
if you can't
you know if you're not an amateur to
just jumping or i don't know you know
something it's it's good yeah
the breath the press and like
you're still putting that energy into
being a better person and you're taking
it to look for the higher power then i
think that could help you for sure
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm good hold on
life is beautiful you know instead of
just like being depressed and
trying to get [ __ ] up so you're right
yeah then you can also take it just on
that higher level
being on a higher level you're like okay
cool i know what level i'm on but i'm
trying to get here right now
it's great advice man
you could do it chilling with the homies
or you could bro i i take so much time
i'll go to a party and go skate on like
a little bit of shrooms you know because
i know where it's going to get me and i
know i'm getting get out of it i'm not
just jumping into it
[ __ ]
aids [ __ ] just get [ __ ] up you know
like it's always on the groovy tip
love it dude oh yeah
man we've been here for a minute i just
want to say thank you for coming through
yeah bro i appreciate you bro thank you
so much where can everybody find uh your
social medias or
where can we look for you because that
movie's gonna be coming out yeah and
that's yo february's not far
it's gonna be right around yeah right
around the corner but oh my god there's
a billboard holy [ __ ]
you get that feeling the night before
and [ __ ] yeah
i'm super stoked so where can everybody
find you at uh you can hit me up on
instagram boo johnson or
i just got back on twitter boo johnson
one
i'm not on snapchat
or tic tac yet
but yeah man you can find me on long
beach with the homies chilling for sure
and then how can everybody look for your
skate shop
um my skate shop
downtown long beach at 333 pine avenue
right there pharmacy right yeah yeah
we'll link everything in the description
right there yeah it's working there oh
good [ __ ] you got my homie slinky
running in matt allen you know all
og homies in long beach that really hold
it down for the city bro
good [ __ ] man well i love every little
message you just dropped right now i
feel like out of all the episodes
this is the one that feels most
beneficial for people
right that's a [ __ ] fact okay thank
you yeah all right so we're on the same
same thing i love it thank you that's
the type of energy i want to bring bro
that was great bro thank you for
everyone out there
yeah you could do that [ __ ]
yeah you're from a shitty place i'm from
a shitty place you're from a shitty
place
yeah there you go you can do something
possible
it's all possible bro
do it don't complain
work hard man be this
bottom
this is how i look at it you feel me you
could be a bottom feeder and that's all
right you feel me cause lobsters those
[ __ ] at the top of the chart in
our life you feel me so y'all you always
gotta start somewhere man so work hard
keep grinding
good [ __ ] appreciate you man yeah bro
thank you thank you guys thank you so
much this has been another episode of
the dope as usual podcast is boo johnson
have a dope ass day
[ __ ] yeah dude
nice i loved it
good [ __ ] man yeah yeah i didn't know
you had a store that's so [ __ ] dead
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]